And I also have a podcast called TLB Hit, TLB.it. You should listen to us if you want to hear two friends just chatting about software engineering practices, which sounds kind of familiar, I think, for you two. But there's far fewer conversations about the interior design of either of our houses. Look, it was one time. Hello, my name is Timur Dumler. I'm the co-host of CBPCast. I'm here at the CBP on C conference. Just talking to Timo about this, actually, he was saying that our podcast is almost like
我也有一个播客叫 TLB Hit，TLB.it。如果你想听两个朋友闲聊软件工程实践，可以来听听我们的节目，我觉得你们俩对这个应该不陌生。不过我们俩节目里可没那么多关于各自家里室内设计的闲聊。听着，那可就那么一次。大家好，我是 Timur Dumler。我是 CppCast 的联合主持人。我其实正跟 Timo 聊这个呢，他刚才说我们的播客简直就像是
complete opposite, because we're sort of like very structured and follow a bit of a formula, whereas you're completely chaotic. But it's like we complement each other. I think we have room for both. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 136, recorded on June 29th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview live from C++ on C 2023, some of the hosts of three other C++ podcasts. We interviewed J.F. Bastian of TLB Hit, Matt Gobboldt of the Two's Compliment podcast, and Timur Dumler and Phil Nash of CppCast. We're here live, except we're not actually live. We just like to say that. We just like to say that. We're live at C++ on C2023.
完全相反的存在，因为我们比较结构化，而且会遵循某种固定的模式，而你们则完全是随性混乱的。但这就好比我们互补一样。我觉得这两者都有存在的空间。欢迎收听第 136 期 ADSP 播客，录制于 2023 年 6 月 29 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，在 2023 年 C++ on Sea 大会上进行现场采访，嘉宾是另外三个 C++ 播客的主持人。我们采访了 TLB Hit 的 J.F. 巴斯辛（J.F. Bastien）、Two's Compliment 播客的马特·戈德博尔特（Matt Godbolt），以及 CppCast 的蒂穆尔·杜姆勒（Timur Dumler）和菲尔·纳什（Phil Nash）。我们现在在现场，虽然其实不是真正的直播。我们只是喜欢这么说。我们只是喜欢这么说。我们在 2023 年 C++ on Sea 大会现场。
It has been a great conference so far. We got Bryce's keynote, last keynote happening tomorrow. And the good news is the slides are mostly finished. It's only 9.30 p.m. the night before the talk. Which is why we're doing this interview right now. We are going to talk to all of these C++ podcasts, except for CBP Club, because they're not represented here. Should I maybe take away that glass of wine? Is CBP Club a real thing?
到目前为止，这次会议非常棒。布莱斯的主题演讲安排在明天，这是最后一场主题演讲。好消息是，幻灯片基本上都做完了。现在是演讲前一晚的晚上 9 点 30 分。这就是为什么我们现在要做这个采访。我们将与所有这些 C++ 播客进行交流，CBP Club 除外，因为他们这里没有代表。我是不是该把那杯葡萄酒拿走？CBP Club 真的存在吗？
Listen, it's a real thing. And they're the least subscribed to C++ podcasts. We've got to think of a more polite way to say that. No, we're saying that so that people go subscribe to them. Oh yeah, definitely. Go subscribe to whatever this is. Actually, I actually don't know. TLB Hit might be less subscribed to.
听着，它是真的存在。而且他们是订阅人数最少的 C++ 播客。我们得想个更礼貌的说法来表达这一点。不，我们这么说就是为了让人去订阅他们。哦，对，绝对的。去订阅这个什么播客吧。其实，我真的不知道。TLB Hit 的订阅人数可能还要更少。
Well, then we should start with them. Let's go find JF, folks. Okay, I know where he is. We've got Mr. JF Bastien. I'm sure that's not the right way of saying his last name, which I should know, because we've been friends for many years. How do we say your last name?
好吧，那我们应该从他们开始。大家去找找 JF 吧。行，我知道他在哪。我们找到了 JF·巴斯辛先生。我确信我念他姓氏的方法不对，其实我早该知道了，因为我们已经认识很多年了。你的姓氏到底怎么读？
Bastien. Okay, I was close. I was close. The chair of the C++ Committee's Evolution Group. And what else do you do? So I work at Woven for Toyota, and I also have a podcast called TLB Hit, TLBH.IT. Yeah, and why did we decide to start with this podcast? It may be the lowest subscribed to podcast, definitely the lowest subscribed to podcast represented here at C++ on C. Is it the lowest subscribed to of all? Probably not.
巴斯辛（Bastien）。好吧，我猜得差不多。我差一点就读对了。C++ 标准委员会演进工作组的主席。你平时还做什么？我在丰田旗下的 Woven 工作，我也主持一个叫 TLB Hit 的播客，网址是 TLBH.IT。对，我们为什么决定从这个播客开始呢？它可能是订阅人数最少的播客，绝对是 C++ on Sea 这里所有有代表的播客里订阅人数最少的。它是所有播客里最少的吗？大概不是吧。
All podcasts? Maybe, maybe. It's a love project that me and my friend Chris put together. And I have to say it inspired you guys to start your podcast. Definitely, definitely. Oh, you confirmed that? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, you guys and Matt.
所有的播客？也许吧，也许是吧。这是我和我朋友克里斯（Chris）一起搞的一个热爱项目。我得说，它还启发了你们开始做播客。绝对的，绝对的。哦，你承认了？对啊，对啊，对啊。没错，你们俩还有马特。
Matt Godbold, too. Yeah. I inspired you guys. And then I get to claim points from your success. You know what, buddy? I'm fine with that because we are not the least subscribed C++ podcast. It's okay. It's quality over quantity. What do you talk about on TLB Hit? Oh, we have like a whole six episodes or something.
还有马特·戈德博尔特。对。我启发了你们。然后我就可以分享你们成功的荣光了。你知道吗，老兄？我对此完全没意见，因为我们可不是订阅人数最少的 C++ 播客。没关系，这是质量胜过数量。你们在 TLB Hit 里聊些什么？哦，我们大概就做了六期节目左右。
There's actually a secret episode that we've never released that we recorded two years ago. We should probably release it. But we talk about just like how computers work or deep programming topics, but we're very particular about it. There's a lot. I was telling Connor our process, and it's
其实还有一个我们从未发布过的秘密节目，那是两年前录制的。我们或许该把它发出来。但我们聊的都是计算机如何工作，或者是深度的编程话题，而且我们在这方面非常挑剔。有很多。我跟康纳讲过我们的制作流程，那就是
multiple hours go into a single episode. So you do this like preparation thing. Yeah, so we have a list of ideas for episodes. We collaboratively write it on a Google Doc asynchronously. Then we block off time to do a rehearsal because we have a script that we write. We decide who's going to hit which topic.
单单一期节目就要花上好几个小时。所以你们会做这种准备工作。对的，我们有一个节目创意列表。我们在谷歌文档（Google Doc）上通过异步协作共同编写。然后我们留出时间进行排练，因为我们写了脚本。我们决定谁负责讲哪个主题。
And that's like an hour and a half to do that prep. And then we do the recording. We used to do the editing ourselves. Now we pay a company to do that prep. And then we do the recording. We used to do the editing ourselves. Now we outsource. We pay a company to do the editing. And, yeah, it's quality. They only have six episodes, though, so it's not that expensive. But Connor and I, Connor got out all the recording equipment,
光是做这个准备就要花一个半小时左右。然后我们进行录音。我们以前自己剪辑。现在我们花钱请一家公司来做准备。然后我们进行录音。我们以前自己剪辑。现在我们外包了。我们花钱请一家公司来剪辑。而且，没错，质量很高。不过他们总共才六期节目，所以也不是很贵。但是康纳和我，康纳把所有的录音设备都拿出来了，
and he's like, you know what we're doing here? We're going to make all the other podcasts look bad. And then this guy comes over, and he's got a process. There's a Google Doc. What is the next episode that we can expect? Oh, I don't know. Chris and I haven't decided. We just like, so the thing is with the time zones,
然后他说，你知道我们在这里做什么吗？我们要让其他所有播客都相形见绌。然后这家伙走过来，他居然有一套流程。还有个谷歌文档。我们接下来可以期待什么主题的节目？哦，我不知道。我和克里斯还没决定。我们只是，问题在于时区，
because I'm in Japan, he's in California, we both have kids. It's hard to find a time that works, right? And so we did a call last weekend just for the kids to talk because they're friends because that means we didn't record because we just had the kids talk yeah and and so like eventually we'll we'll be like oh we should do another episode right around the time i think connor was going to remove us from the active podcast list that he maintains well uh so what what were you doing here this week? Tell us about your talk. So my talk is actually, we had a podcast,
因为我在日本，他在加州，我们俩都有孩子。很难找到一个合适的时间，对吧？所以我们上周末打了个电话，只是为了让孩子们聊聊天，因为他们是好朋友，这意味着我们根本没录音，因为我们只是让孩子们聊天了。没错，所以最后我们会觉得，哦，差不多在康纳打算把我从他维护的活跃播客列表中除名的时候，我们该做另一期节目了。那么，你这周在这里做什么？给我们讲讲你的演讲吧。我的演讲其实是，我们有一个播客，
our episode number one, second episode, which we count from zero, is Star Car Star Zero Equals Zero. So it's an idea that I had years ago to do as a talk, like a conference talk. And I told Chris about it
我们的第一期节目，或者说从零开始数的第二期节目，叫做“星巴克-星-零等于零”（Star Car Star Zero Equals Zero）。这是我几年前萌生的一个想法，想把它做成一个演讲，比如大会演讲。我把这个想法告诉了克里斯，
and he was like, let's do a podcast about that. So we did a podcast about it. What is the premise of this talk slash podcast episode? And also, this wasn't the talk that you gave at a committee meeting at one point on different programming. That was totally different.
他说，我们不如就此做一个播客吧。于是我们就做了一个相关的播客。这个演讲兼播客节目的核心前提是什么？而且，这也不是你当年在委员会会议上关于不同编程语言的那个演讲吧？那个完全不同。
I only give talks once, usually. So it's a one-off. It's a shame that that talk that you gave, I can't remember if it was at Cologne or at Belfast, but that talk was fantastic. You should give that at a conference. It was different programming language histories. Oh, I remember that, yeah.
我通常一个演讲只讲一次。所以这是一次性的。真遗憾，你当年做的那个演讲——我不记得是在科隆还是在贝尔法斯特了——那个演讲棒极了。你应该在大会上再讲一次。那是关于不同编程语言的历史。哦，我想起来了，对。
CppCon 2020. I gave that talk about JITs. Oh. Yeah, yeah. Link in the description, folks. We'll find it. We'll link it. Go watch it.
2020 年 CppCon 大会。我做过那个关于 JIT 的演讲。哦。对，对，对。各位，链接就在简介里。我们会找到它。我们会把链接放上去。快去看看吧。
All right, but back to this talk. You gave the title of this talk, but what is it about? Yeah, so StarCars-star-zero-equals-zero-semi-colon. And so it's an interview question that I've used more than 100 times. You are a cruel interviewer. Yeah, but it's for systems and compiler people that I've used it. And so the idea is I write, like, int main curly brace star-car-star-zero-equals-zero-semi-colon, return zero, curly brace.
好吧，言归正传，回到这个演讲。你给这个演讲起了个标题，但它到底是关于什么的？对，标题是 StarCars-star-zero-equals-zero-semi-colon（星星-星-零-等于-零-分号）。这是一个我用过一百多次的面试题。你真是一个残酷的面试官。对，不过我是用它来考察系统和编译器方向的人才的。这个想法是，我写下一段代码，比如 int main 花括号 star-car-star-zero-equals-zero-分号，return 0，花括号。
And I say, talk to me about this code. And sometimes there are listed emotions, like this is terrible code and things like that. But the goal is to see your systems or compiler person, like what calls out to you? Do you want to talk about the front end, about undefined behavior, about things like that? Do you want to talk about how the machine works? Do you want to tell me how silicon works?
然后我说，跟我聊聊这段代码。有时候会列出一些情绪，比如这是糟糕的代码之类的。但目的是看看你的系统或编译器背景的人，什么东西能引起你的注意？你想谈谈前端、未定义行为，还是类似的事情？你想谈谈机器是如何工作的吗？你想告诉我硅片是如何工作的吗？
And I've never gotten the same answer ever. And so my talk is kind of breaking down the different approaches, how you could answer that, and showing a lot of the systems and compiler people like to look under the hood and poke at stuff and see how it works. And so that's basically the talk. And it's also a bit of an art project because I have nice animations and stuff. It's definitely better than your talk, Bryce.
我从来没有得到过相同的答案。所以我的演讲有点像是在剖析不同的方法，以及你可以如何回答这个问题，并展示许多系统和编译器从业者喜欢揭开引擎盖一探究竟、去戳一戳看看它是如何运作的。所以这基本上就是这个演讲的内容。而且它也算是一个艺术项目，因为我制作了精美的动画之类的东西。这绝对比你的演讲要好，布莱斯。
That may be true, but we won't know until I finish making the talk. Also, you're talking about this talk quasi in the past tense. It's tomorrow, correct? It is tomorrow. I totally thought it would happen today. It's going to be amazing. Is it scheduled against my talk? No, it's not against your talk.
这倒未必，不过在我的演讲做完之前我们是不会知道了。另外，你刚才谈论这个演讲时，用的似乎是过去时。是明天，对吧？确实是明天。我完全以为是今天呢。这一定会非常精彩。它跟我有冲突吗？没有，没跟你的演讲冲突。
You're a keynote. Oh, that your talk. You're a keynote. Oh, that's right. I'm a keynote. Oh, my God. He baited me. He's not a keynote. He's an end note. End note.
你是主题演讲。哦，对哦，你的演讲。你是主题演讲。哦，对哦。我是主题演讲。天哪。他给我下套。他不是主题演讲（keynote）。他是闭幕演讲（end note）。闭幕演讲。
I got you. I don't think I've ever been more upset live on the pod than right now. Stop it, Ryan. I thought you were. Link in the description to the pictures of Connor being mortified. I thought you were being daft. I'm not, folks, I'm going to back off for the rest of this pod. I've clearly had too much wine, and I'm just going to be in the background. What happened there is that Connor thought he had a chance to get me,
我中计了。我想我在播客直播中从来没有像现在这样沮丧过。别这样，瑞恩。我以为你是。简介里有康纳感到羞愧的照片的链接。我以为你在犯傻呢。我没有，各位，接下来的播客里我要退居二线了。我显然喝了太多酒，我就在背景里待着吧。刚才发生的事情是，康纳以为他有机会抓住我的把柄，
and he activated my trap card. So anything else you want to tell the people? How about a question about have you been to C++ on C before? Is this your first time? How did you find the conference? Oh, yeah, first time here. So I decided I wanted to rotate different conferences because there's a lot of new ones coming out that are really interesting, like CoreCPP, the C++ North. And so with kids, it's a bit hard to travel,
于是他触发了我的陷阱卡。所以，你还有什么想告诉大家的吗？比如问一个问题：你以前来过 C++ on Sea 吗？这是你第一次来吗？你觉得这个会议怎么样？哦，对，第一次来。所以我决定轮流参加不同的会议，因为现在有很多新会议涌现出来，非常有趣，比如 CoreCPP、C++ North。因为有了孩子，出行有点困难，
so I picked C++ on C because it seemed cool. It's a place to give a talk. Next year, I'll try some other one. It's nice to meet different people and communities. And so far, it's a really nice conference. You can see France from the balcony here, which is funny. So we're on the sea in the south of England. You get to see France sometimes.
所以我选了 C++ on Sea，因为看起来很酷。这是一个做演讲的好地方。明年我会去尝试另一个。认识不同的人和社区感觉很好。到目前为止，这是一个非常棒的会议。从这里的阳台上可以看到法国，这挺搞笑的。我们在英格兰南部的海边。有时你能看到法国。
It's funny. But yeah, it's great. Talks have been great. People are nice. So really, really enjoyable. The one downside is Bryce is here, but otherwise it's great. So wait, last question is, I don't actually think you have necessarily told our listeners
这挺有意思的。不过，是的，非常棒。演讲都很精彩。人也很好。所以真的非常、非常享受。唯一的缺点是布莱斯在这里，除此之外都很好。等等，最后一个问题是，我觉得你其实不一定告诉过我们的听众，
why they might want to listen to TLB Hit. You haven't actually explained what the acronym, because when I first started listening to TLB Hit. Wait, you don't know what TLB is? Okay, listen. Don't shame me, okay? I'm a high-level person. We've discussed this. You're the low-level person.
他们为什么会想听 TLB Hit。你其实没有解释这个缩写是什么意思，因为当我第一次开始听 TLB Hit 的时候……等等，你不知道 TLB 是什么？好吧，听着。别羞辱我，好吗？我是个高层人士。我们讨论过这个了。你是底层人士。
You work at NVIDIA. Yeah, you know what? And I told them not to hire me, okay? I said, I don't know anything about hardware. So anyways, give a little pitch for your podcast. Why might our listeners. Also explain what a TLB is. Yeah, so you don't necessarily need to subscribe. It's just a LovePad project,
你在英伟达工作。对，你知道吗？我告诉过他们不要雇我，好吗？我说，我对硬件一无所知。不管怎样，为你的播客打个小广告吧。为什么我们的听众可能会……顺便解释一下什么是 TLB。对，所以你不一定非要订阅。这只是一个热爱项目，
so whatever. I think our episodes are pretty good, but it's fine. Definitely better than ours. But yeah, and if you work for NVIDIA, you don't necessarily need a TLB, right? So NVIDIA is all about throughput, not latency. You could turn off the caches, and it's like a 10% per fit, whereas for CPUs, you don't get that. So a TLB is a translation look-aside buffer when they do virtual to physical address translation, either within the cache or in the MMU just before the memory.
无所谓啦。我觉得我们的节目相当不错，不过也行。绝对比我们的好。但是，如果你在英伟达工作，你其实不一定需要 TLB，对吧？英伟达关注的是吞吐量，而不是延迟。你可以关闭缓存，性能可能只受百分之十的影响，而对于 CPU，你就得不到这种待遇。所以 TLB 是转换旁视缓冲区（Translation Lookaside Buffer），当他们在缓存中或在内存前的 MMU 中进行虚拟地址到物理地址的转换时就会用到它。
And so it's a cache for the address translation from virtual to physical. And so it makes your hardware faster, unless you're NVIDIA, in which case you don't care because you hide that latency with a lot of throughput. So you don't need it, Connor. You're okay. Perfect. Alright, I think we should wrap there because I see that they're bringing out
它是虚拟地址到物理地址转换的缓存。所以它能让你的硬件运行得更快，除非你是英伟达，这种情况下你根本不在乎，因为你用高吞吐量掩盖了延迟。所以你不需要它，康纳。你没事的。完美。好吧，我想我们该在这里结束了，因为我看到他们把我的
my dessert and I don't want my ice cream to melt. We're going to take a break. We've got two more people. I know, but we're going to take a break. I told Bryce, why don't we do this after dessert? And he said, I got a schedule. We're going to take a little break. You're going to finish your wine. Any final words? All right. Well, enjoy dessert. All right. Wait, do you want any, any, uh, you know, hot takes? You want to just trash the other pods? What do you, I mean, I don't listen to your pod, so it's okay.
甜点端上来了，我可不想让我的冰淇淋化掉。我们要休息一下。我们还有两个人要采访。我知道，但我们要休息一下。我跟布莱斯说过，为什么我们不在甜点之后再做这个？他说，我得按时间表来。我们要休息一小会儿。你要把你的酒喝完。还有什么最后的遗言吗？好吧。好吧，享用甜点吧。等等，你想要什么，任何，呃，你知道的，辛辣的见解吗？你想顺便贬低一下其他播客吗？你觉得，我是说，我不听你们的播客，所以没关系。
Mic drop. I think we're going to leave it there folks We'll be back in a few minutes Let's go ambush him We have refilled on wine I have stolen a bottle of wine from my table Mr. Godball Hello We require you
把话筒一扔。我想我们就到此为止吧，各位。我们几分钟后回来。让我们去突袭他。我们的酒又倒满了。我从我的桌子上偷了一瓶酒。戈德博尔特先生。你好。我们需要你。
You require me Alright, oh I'm being ushered away from my table. Oh, Brian has tripped over a chair. I'm falling over chairs. You did pretty well going backwards. Yeah. I'm not doing a great job of holding the microphone.
你们需要我。好吧，哦，我被请离了我的座位。哦，布莱斯被椅子绊倒了。我从椅子上摔下去了。你倒退着走得挺好。对。我拿话筒的姿势可不太好。
And actually holding it to my face. We have to hear you too, right? I guess we do, but I'm very loud. But anyways, we are back again. Connor has a fresh glass of wine. Wait, yes, I do. Don't worry. Teamers, we will find you and Phil.
而且还得把它贴着脸。我们得听见你说话，对吧？我想是的，但我声音很大。不管怎样，我们又回来了。康纳有了一杯新酒。等等，是的，我确实有。别担心，蒂穆尔，我们会找到你和菲尔的。
Actually, you want to say hi first, Teamer? I'd like to say hi first. Just interrupt the... Hello, how are you doing? Good. All right, we'll find you and Phil. So that's Teamer from CppCast, but we're talking to Matt Gobble from Two's Compliment.
其实，蒂穆尔，你想先打个招呼吗？我想先打个招呼。打断一下……嗨，你们过得怎么样？很好。好吧，我们会找到你和菲尔的。那是 CppCast 的蒂穆尔，但我们现在正在跟 Two's Compliment 的马特·戈德博尔特聊天。
I don't even think Bryce knew the name of your podcast. I did not. You saw it on my face! Why would Bryce know my podcast? Who listens to it, honestly? I mean, I do, and many others do. Bryce does not even listen to our podcast. Yeah, well, that gives you a certain amount of link.
我甚至觉得布莱斯都不知道你们播客的名字。我确实不知道。你从我脸上看出来了！布莱斯怎么会知道我的播客叫什么？老实说，谁会听啊？我是说，我听，还有很多其他人也听。布莱斯甚至不听我们的播客。好吧，那说明你还是有一定的知名度的。
Okay, alright, but to be fair, I'm here when our podcast is recorded, so I've listened to it once. I listened to it live. I had the best experience of it. I mean, there's been at least six or seven episodes now that you weren't there for it, and I've listened to it once. I listened to it live. I had the best experience of it. I mean, there's been at least six or seven episodes now that you weren't there for, and you've definitely never listened to those. No, I listened
好吧，好吧，但公平地说，我们录播客的时候我都在场，所以我听过一次。我是现场听的。我体验到了最好的效果。我是说，有至少六七期节目你都不在现场，而我只听过一次。我是现场听的。我体验到了最好的效果。我是说，有至少六七期节目你都不在现场，你绝对从来没听过那些。不，我听过
to the CPP Now one, the first one that I wasn't on. I listened to it. Oh, that's true. With Ben Dean, which Tony joined halfway through. Anyways, we're here with Matt Gobble, and unfortunately, Ben Rady, we're very sad that you're not here as well. Your voice is missed as the co-host of Two's Compliment.
CPP Now 那期，就是我没去的那期第一期。我听过。哦，那倒是真的。有本·迪恩（Ben Dean），托尼中途也加入了。不管怎样，我们在这里和马特·戈德博尔特在一起，不幸的是，本·雷迪（Ben Rady），我们非常遗憾你没能来到现场。作为 Two's Compliment 的联合主持人，大家都很想念你的声音。
Tell us about your podcast, Matt. What do I need to say about my... I mean, my podcast is not really specifically about anything. It's just programming in general. But because it's me, I do do a lot of C++ related stuff. So I guess in a way,
跟我们讲讲你的播客吧，马特。关于我的播客，我需要说些什么呢？我的播客其实没有特定的主题。它只是泛泛地聊编程。但因为是我在做，所以我确实做了很多与 C++ 相关的内容。所以我想在某种程度上，
it's a bit like ADS-B, where notionally it's about languages in general, but it kind of has a bent towards the kind of stuff that you do in your day job. Mine is more towards what I guess I like doing rather than what anyone really has asked for. Wait, wait, wait. You like doing C++? Because I'm not here by choice, man. I mean, so we tend to talk a lot about more low-level stuff, although
它有点像 ADS-B，表面上它是关于通用语言的，但它有点偏向于你在日常工作中做的那类事情。我的节目更偏向于我喜欢做的事，而不是别人真正要求的事。等等，等等，等等。你喜欢写 C++？因为我来这里可不是出于自愿的，老兄。我是说，我们往往会讨论更多底层的东西，虽然
Ben then talks about testing, so we get a bit of both. I was going to say, Ben Rady does, that is, you're the C++ low-latency guy, and Ben Rady is the testing guy. That's an interesting dynamic. It is, it is, and I think it's what makes it an interesting combo, so our sort of origin story is that we were both
本后来谈论了测试，所以我们两方面都沾了一点。我正想说，本·雷迪就是这样，你是 C++ 低延迟专家，本·雷迪是测试专家。这是一种很有趣的动态。确实是，确实是，我认为这正是让它成为一个有趣组合的原因，所以我们的起源故事是，我们俩当时都
planning to go into video games, and then life caught up with Ben, and he went off into the trading industry via a bunch of other ways. And I did do games for a while, and then we have rendezvoused in the trading industry. So we're like, it's the sliding doors kind of feel. They're like, here's the same person that's taken two routes to get to the same place. What games did you work on?
计划进入电子游戏行业，然后生活追赶上了本，他通过各种其他途径进入了交易行业。而我做了一段时间的游戏，然后我们在交易行业重聚了。所以我们感觉就像是“滑动门”（Sliding Doors）电影里的情节。就像是，这是同一个人通过两条不同的路线最终到达了同一个地方。你参与过制作什么游戏？
So I worked on a PlayStation 1 game, which was probably made before you were born, Bryce. Now I'm saying this. 94? Not before I was born. Not before I was born. I was all of two. Oh, my gosh.
我参与制作过一款 PlayStation 1 游戏，可能在你出生之前就制作出来了，布莱斯。现在我这么说了。94 年？没在我出生前。没在我出生前。我当时整整两岁呢。哦，天哪。
Actually, I think it was a little later. I don't think the internet agrees with that statement. I know Hannah definitely has an issue with that. Hannah has opinions about your age. So you worked on this PlayStation 1 game. What was it called? It was called Croc Legend of the Gobos. I worked on a SWAT.
其实，我觉得稍微晚了一点。我觉得互联网并不同意这种说法。我知道汉娜（Hannah）绝对对这种说法有异议。汉娜对你的年龄很有看法。所以你参与制作了这款 PlayStation 1 游戏。它叫什么名字？它叫《古柯历险记》（Croc Legend of the Gobos）。我参与过一款 SWAT。
Yeah, stop it. So inevitably, you know what my nickname was during the process of that. I don't. All right. Well, Matt Gobalt. Matt Gobo. Yeah, yeah. There's a lot of laughing that you probably can't hear off of the mic right now.
行了，别说了。所以不可避免地，你知道我在那期间的外号叫什么吗？我不知道。好吧。马特·戈德博尔特。马特·戈博。对，对。有一大堆笑声，你现在可能在麦克风外面听不见。
It's getting picked up. You're getting picked up. We got it. We got it. Yeah, there's a lot of laughing that you probably can't hear off of the mic right now. It's getting picked up. You're getting picked up. We got it. We got it. Yeah, he is, yeah. So that was a PlayStation game, and I worked on the PC port of it. I also did a swap. It's one of the swap franchise games for the Xbox and PlayStation 2.
被收录进去了。你被收录进去了。我们听到了。我们听到了。对，他被收录进去了。所以那是款 PlayStation 游戏，我做了它的 PC 移植版。我还做过 SWAT。它是 Xbox 和 PlayStation 2 的 SWAT 系列游戏之一。
What was it like programming on the PlayStation 1 platform, which I can only imagine was quirky and specialized and challenging? All of the Sony platforms are exactly that. They are bonkers. I didn't spend very much time working on the PlayStation 1 version, so I didn't get to really get to grips with it. I was originally just a tester. I'd been hired during my university degree,
在 PlayStation 1 平台上编程是什么感觉？我可以想象那是古怪、专业且充满挑战的。索尼所有的平台都是这样的。它们简直疯狂。我没有花太多时间在 PlayStation 1 版本上，所以我没有真正深入了解它。我最初只是一个测试员。我是在读大学期间被雇用的，
and they were like, we want you to stop and start working for us. And I'm like, I can't. I said, well, I can come back in the summer holidays. But they didn't know what to do with a programmer who was going to come in and be there for a few weeks. And I said, here's a controller. You can be a tester. That was a really interesting experience, right? We had just decided, or we just discovered that if you videotape the PlayStation while you're playing, it's an amazing reproduction-like system. So if you get it to crash or blow up or you jump through a wall or whatever, you can rewind the tape and show the developer,
他们说，我们希望你停下来开始为我们工作。我说，我不能。我说，好吧，我可以在暑假回来。但他们不知道该拿一个只来几周的程序员怎么办。他们说，给你个手柄。你可以当个测试员。那是一次非常有趣的经历，对吧？我们当时刚刚决定，或者说我们刚发现，如果你在玩 PlayStation 时用录像机把它录下来，这是一个神奇的复现系统。所以如果你让它崩溃、爆炸或者你穿墙而过了，你可以倒带录像，向开发人员展示，
look, it happens. I actually have proof. Because, you know, they'll be like, there's no way you could get through the wall there. But then, yeah, the PlayStation 2 was a real class device. I mean, it was bonkers and crazy. And in a sort of good ways, if you love the kind of like the way
看，它发生了。我有证据。因为，你知道的，他们会说，你绝对不可能从那面墙穿过去。但是，是的，PlayStation 2 是一款真正的顶级设备。我的意思是，它既疯狂又古怪。从某种好的方面来说，如果你喜欢那种将
the disparate group of awesome hardware components are put together in a box, shipped to you with a Japanese instruction manual that no one speaks Japanese, and no standard libraries at all, and off you go. It took us like three months to get like a single triangle on the screen, which was like so awesome. And then, add to the mix of it, Microsoft were doing the Xbox, the original Xbox at this time. And they, you know, the whole Steve Bourne were jumping around on stage type thing, they were all about the developer. And so they shipped us a device with Visual Studio, a plug-in that you just press a button and it goes off of your machine and it starts running on the Xbox that's plugged in.
各种迥然不同的出色硬件组件拼装在一个盒子里，随货附赠一本谁也看不懂日语的日文说明书，而且完全没有标准库，然后你就开始干了。我们花了大约三个月时间才在屏幕上搞出一个单独的三角形，当时觉得太棒了。然后，雪上加霜的是，微软当时正在搞 Xbox，也就是最初的 Xbox。而且他们，你知道的，史蒂夫·鲍尔默（Steve Ballmer）在舞台上蹦蹦跳跳的那种风格，他们全心全意为了开发者。所以他们给我们寄了一台设备，里面装着 Visual Studio，还有一个插件，你只需按一下按钮，它就会从你的机器上发送出去，并在插在上面的 Xbox 上运行。
It was amazing to see the difference between this arcane thing that was like an embedded system that you didn't really understand and the full bells and whistles you can put break points in they just work and all that kind of nonsense it was awesome and that was my first run-in actually with nvidia so that was what no i tell a lie that was my second run-in i remember getting a reaver tnt one of the original ones they shipped out in this beautiful brushed aluminium case that was like a briefcase and you opened it up and it was all foam except for just the card in the middle because they were trying to woo developers like us to actually like port our games to use it and stuff how this was back this was back when like like, NVIDIA was, like, a scrappy young company.
看到这种神秘兮兮、像嵌入式系统又让人捉摸不透的东西，与功能齐全、你可以设置断点而且开箱即用的完整工具之间的巨大差异，真是令人惊叹，那种感觉太棒了，这也是我第一次真正接触英伟达——等等，我撒谎了，那是我第二次接触英伟达。我记得我弄到了一块 Riva TNT，那是他们最初发货的产品之一，装在一个漂亮的拉丝铝制手提箱里，就像一个公文箱，你打开它，除了正中间的卡之外全是泡沫，因为他们当时正试图吸引像我们这样的开发者去把游戏移植过来使用它。这还是在……这还是在英伟达只是一家充满活力的小公司的时候。
It certainly was. I remember going to conferences like E3 and chatting to some of the original engineers that were around. And our name is escaping my mind right now. But, like, they were definitely the underdog in this, right? They were contending with, you know, 3D effects was, like, their main competitor now. And look how different the world is now. Yes, we are now a trillion-dollar company, and we do not send developers shiny brushed aluminum cases with our cards.
确实如此。我记得去参加 E3 等会议，跟一些最初的工程师聊天。他们的名字我现在有点想不起来了。但是，他们当时绝对是挑战者，对吧？他们在与 3Dfx 竞争，后者当时是他们的主要竞争对手。看看现在这个世界有多么不同。是的，我们现在是一家市值万亿美元的公司，我们不会再给开发者送闪亮的拉丝铝制手提箱和显卡了。
Developers are knocking on your door. They're like zombie hordes outside. Give us them, yeah. Do you miss the time that you spend as a game developer? Is there anything that you miss about it? I do miss having a very constrained environment in console development, for sure. And now I'm being photographed here.
开发者都在敲你们的门。他们就像外面的僵尸群一样。快给我们显卡吧。你怀念作为游戏开发者的那段时光吗？有什么关于它的事情是你怀念的吗？我确实怀念主机开发中那种非常受限的环境，肯定的。现在我正在这里被拍照。
In console development, where you have a very well-defined system that everyone's going to have under their TV, and you can do any hacks you come up with are almost certainly going to work on all the consoles, at least the generation that I was involved with. I don't know if that's true anymore. I think there's a lot more leeway in terms of the parts
在主机开发中，你拥有一个定义非常明确的系统，每个人都会在电视机下面摆放一台，而且你无论想出什么奇技淫巧，几乎都肯定能在所有主机上运行，至少在我参与的那一代主机上是这样的。我不知道现在还是不是这样。我觉得在他们可以随时替换的零件方面有了更多的灵活性。所以过去我经常把 PS2 的手册摊在膝盖上，坐在那儿计算会有多少个周期，然后打开手册说，哦，我可以在这里塞进一个除法。你知道你肯定能塞进一个除法，或者你知道你可以在特定的时间内通过内存总线传输到某个地方，而且它
that they can switch in and out. So I used to sit there with the PS2 manuals open in my lap and you would sit there and count how many cycles it would be and you'd open the thing and go like, oh, I can fit a divide in here. And you knew you could definitely get a divide in or you knew that you could get a transfer over through the memory bus to something in a particular time and it would
永远都是那个时间，因为它是唯一的变量。现在你大概不能玩那种把戏了，不过 PC 游戏环境非常不同，我能想象得到。是的，现在的绝大多数主机都有这种问题，你在硬件之间隔了太多层驱动程序，而不是直接去操作寄存器。所以，回到 Xbox，我关于英伟达的故事是，微软无法告诉我们。你知道的，我们习惯了这种想法，我们有寄存器，我们操作寄存器，我们在各个地方写入内存，然后所有人都得到了 Direct X，然后他们说，
always be that time because it was the one thing and now you can't do those kinds of tricks i don't think but very different on pc gaming environment i imagine and yeah most consoles these days are have that thing where you've got so many layers of drivers between you and the hardware instead of just literally poking registers so yeah going back to the Xbox, my sort of NVIDIA story about that was that, like, Microsoft couldn't tell us. You know, we're used to this idea that we've got registers, we poke registers, we write memory in places, and then we're all given direct X, and we're like,
我不能在你的播客里说这个词，但请不要那样做。我们想看看硬件是如何工作的。所以微软就说，我们不能告诉你这是怎么工作的，因为我们与英伟达有协议，他们不准我们告诉你它是怎么工作的。所以你必须使用 D3D 接口。然后他们会礼貌地咳嗽一声，接着说，如果你打开 D3D.h 并看看宏实际上对应的是什么，
I can't say this word on your podcast, but please don't do that. We would like to see how the hardware works. So Microsoft were like, we can't tell you how this works because we have an agreement with NVIDIA, and they won't let us tell you how it works. So you have to use the D3D interfaces. And then they would politely cough, and then they'd say, if you open up D3D.h and look at what the macros actually correspond to,
你大概就能推断出它是如何真正工作的。所以那是我们所有人做的第一件事，就是把它打开说，哦，太酷了。我们立刻就去用底层的东西做了一大堆事情，你知道的。所以那非常有趣。我确实怀念那个方面。但是，你知道的，我现在在交易行业工作。
you can probably infer how it really works. And so that was the first thing we all did, was like crack it open and go, oh, that's cool. And we immediately went off and did a whole bunch of stuff with the lower level stuff, you know. So that was a lot of fun. And I do miss that aspect of it. But, you know, I now work in trading.
我们在那里也有类似的问题。我们，你知道的，当然是在低延迟领域，我目前没在做这个，但金钱能买到的东西是有限的。存在的计算机数量是有限的。你知道你可以在一定程度上超频它们，但归根结底，你面对的是一套受物理限制的约束条件。这就好比，这东西能跑多快？电缆能有多长？大家都在用英特尔机器或其他什么东西，需要消耗多少个时钟周期？不过，难道你不能确保你们的机柜比其他人的机柜更靠近电缆插墙的墙壁吗？
And we've got a similar-ish issue there. We've, you know, certainly in the lower latency stuff, which I'm not doing this at the moment, but there's only so much that money can buy. There's only so many computers that exist. You you know you can overclock them to some extent but ultimately you've got like a um a physics constrained set of uh of of constraints right it's like well how fast can this go and how long can the cables be and how how many few clock cycles can everyone's got an intel machine or or whatever but can't you make sure that your rack's closer to where the cables plug into the wall than the other guy's rack?
不，这真的是一件大事。所以在我的上一份工作和现在这份工作之间，我实际上在一家交易所工作过。所以我得以看到 TCP 连接的另一端发生了什么。当时我们拥有的最精密的设备之一是一个超级酷的东西，它向电缆发射激光束，并测量另一端未插入时反射回来的光，它能告诉我们电缆有多长、有多少个弯折，这样我们就可以精确测量它们的长度，从而向我们的客户保证他们拥有精确的 800 英尺
No, that is a really big deal. So in between my current gig and the previous gig, I actually worked in an exchange. And so I got to see what happens on the other side of the TCP connection. And one of the most fancy bits of equipment that we had at the time was a super cool thing that fired a laser beam down a cable and it measured the reflection of it not being plugged in at the other end and it could tell us how long the cable was and how kinked it was so that we could measure exactly how long they were so that we could give our clients the guarantee that they had exactly 800 feet
或者诸如此类的长度，这样就不会有人受到任何特权优待。所以，我的意思是，这是一件大事，当你告诉交易员说“嘿，听着，我们想向所有人出售这种访问权限，每个人都在同一起跑线上”时，这是一个非常重要的东西。（这里“同一起跑线”我加上引号），不过，是的，这是一个有趣的领域，但我不再做那种事情了。我确实有点怀念那种东西，因为同样地，这里有一种军备竞赛的感觉，这是一种纯粹的智力锻炼，思考着“我怎么能用少一个周期的代价来更快地完成这个”或者类似的事情，不过，是的，这确实挺有趣的。
or whatever it was so that nobody was privileged in any way. So, I mean, it's a big deal it's a really important thing when you're telling traders like hey look we want to sell you this access everyone has a level playing field level i'm going to say with air quotes here but yeah it's uh it's an interesting it's an interesting world but i don't do that kind of stuff anymore i do miss that a bit as well because again there's this kind of like arms race type thing it's a purely intellectual exercise of like how can i do this with one fewer cycle or this much faster stuff but yeah no it's good fun that is fascinating we're gonna have to have matt back on a few more
太迷人了。我们以后得请马特多来几次了。我们绝对得请马特回来录制一期节目，然后把它拆分成三到四集。以防有人忘了，我们在跟 Two's Compliment 的联合主持人戈德博尔特聊天。那么，你为什么不跟我们讲讲你的播客，以及为什么人们应该听它呢？如果你想听两个朋友闲聊软件工程实践，就可以来听听我们的节目，我觉得你们俩对这个应该不陌生。不过我们俩节目里可没那么多关于各自家里室内设计的闲聊。听着，那可就那么一次。就那么一次。
times we definitely have to have matt back on for a recording that will get turned into three or four episodes in case folks have forgotten we're talking to Gobble, co-host of a podcast of Two's Compliment. So why don't you tell us a bit about your podcast and why people should listen to it? You should listen to us if you want to hear two friends just chatting about software engineering practices, which sounds kind of familiar, I think, for you two. But there's far fewer conversations about the interior design of either of our houses. Look, it was one time. It was one time.
才不只一次呢。大概有七期节目都是这样。那就是让布莱斯你以 10 倍速加速你的声音的原因。我当时正搬进公寓。我很兴奋，家具终于到了。家具根本没到，布莱斯。你当时在向听众解释你床铺的送达时间表。
It was not one time. It was like seven episodes. That's what started the whole 10X speeding up your voice, Bryce. I was moving into the apartment. I was excited that the furniture had arrived. It hadn't arrived, Bryce. You were explaining to the listener your arrival schedule of your bed. They did not hear it because I
他们根本没听到，因为我把你的声音 10 倍速快进了。是的。里面没有家具。这大概就是 Two's Compliment 是个更好的播客的原因。它更切题。这大概是真的。也许稍微更切题一点，但我们的更新频率绝对赶不上你们俩。你们好像每周都能产出一期。
10x'd the hell out of your voice. Yes. There's no furniture. Probably why Two's Coppola is a better podcast to listen to. It's more on topic. That's probably true. Maybe a little bit more on topic, but we're nowhere near as consistent as you two. You seem to get something out every week.
秘诀就是低质量、高数量。秘诀在于低质量，以及康纳的奉献精神和辛勤工作。而且我们也是三十多岁充满活力的年轻男士。确实如此。有时我听到背景里有小孩子的叫声，这温暖了我的心。我想你还有几只宠物。狗，猫。
How many episodes now? The key is low quality, high quantity. The key is low quality and also Connor's dedication and hard work. And also we are young 30-something men. That's true. Sometimes I hear kids in the background and it warms my heart. You've also got, I think, a couple pets. Dogs, cats.
是的，是的。当我听到这个而你说“哦，对不起”的时候，这是一个非常可爱的细节。我当时就想，不，这证明了你不是机器人。谢谢，我想是的。我通过了图灵测试，因为我太太偶尔会在背景里发出声音。现在，康纳，
Yeah, yeah. And that is a lovely touch when I hear it and you're like, oh, I think, a couple pets. Dogs, cats. That is a lovely touch when I hear it and you're like, oh, I'm sorry about that. And I was like, no, that proves that you're not a robot. Thank you, I think. I passed the Turing test because my wife may make a noise in the background occasionally. Now, Connor,
我想你有一个问题要问马特。哦，是的。所以，我们一直在讨论你是播客联合主持人以及你的很多工作经验。但今天我们还在同一个时间段里进行了竞争，都在同一时间发表演讲。所以，如果我没记错的话，你的演讲标题是，这也是为了那百分之二不知道的听众。但如果这个播客在 Reddit 或其他地方火了，出现了一些新听众：马特·戈德博尔特在 C++ 社区里是出了名的，在其他编程语言
I think you had a question for Matt. Oh, yes. So, we've been talking about the fact that you are co-host of a podcast and a lot of your work experience. But also today we competed in the same time slot, both speaking at the same time. So and the title of your talk, if I'm not mistaken, is which is also for maybe the two percent of our listeners that don't know. But if this if this podcast pops off on the Reddits or whatever and there are first-time listeners matt gobbalt is infamous in the c++ community and should be more famous in other programming language
社区里也应该更出名，因为你有一个叫 Compiler Explorer（编译器资源管理器）的网站，它做的是反编译……我想这其实不算反编译，不管怎样，重点是现在有——我都不知道有多少个网站了。是的，我们得把酒杯举起来。康纳手里拿着一杯酒，下面可是价值 1000 美元的录音设备啊。但大概有，我想说，50 种语言，包括 Haskell 和 Ada 这种跟 C++ 完全没关系的语言。Ada 是其中一种语言吗？Ada 是其中一种语言。
communities because you have a website called compiler explorer that does uh decompilation so you can look at the assembly i guess it's not decompilation but anyways the point is there's like now i don't even know how many websites. Yeah, we've got to lift up the wine glass. We have $1,000 of recording equipment that Connor is holding a wine glass over. But there's like, I want to say, 30 languages, including languages like Haskell and Ada, which have nothing to do. Is Ada one of the languages, I think? Ada is one of the languages.
为什么？因为主要的贡献者之一想把他们日常工作中使用的语言添加进去。其实我不能这么说。我认识美国编程语言委员会的一些 Ada 人士。不过，不，我们现在有 50 种语言了。50 种？是的。秘诀在于把它变成一种自助式的服务，让你添加自己的语言，
Why? Because one of the main contributors wanted to add the language that they work in in a day job. I actually can't. I know some of the Ada people from the U.S. Programming Languages Committee. But no, we have 50 languages now. 50? Yeah. The trick has been making it into a sort of self-service thing to add your own languages,
添加你自己的编译器，一切都是开源的。我认为戈德博尔特对 C++ 等语言具有变革性的意义，因为它允许你直接去进行你在其他语言中可以轻松进行的 REPL 风格的编程。我要说两点。第一，那是百分之百真的。
add your own compilers, everything's open source. I would argue that Godbolt has been transformative to languages like C++ because it allows you to just go and do the REPL-style programming that you can do easily in other languages. There's two things I'll say. One, that's 100% true.
C++ 在过去……因为 C++ 本身就很大。戈德博尔特比 C++11 的影响还要大吗？是的。我的意思是，绝对比 C++20 的影响还要大。比 C++20 还大？Compiler Explorer 是哪一年推出的？
The best thing to happen to C++ in the last... Because C++ was big. Was Godbolt bigger than C++11? Yeah. I mean, definitely bigger than 20. Bigger than 20. What year did Compiler Explorer come out?
2012 年。2012 年。所以，是的，绝对是在过去……那刚好过了一个十年。在过去的 12 年里，或者说自从 C++11 以来，Compiler Explorer 是发生在 C++ 身上最好的事情。我们是怎么知道这一点的？
2012. 2012. So, yes, definitely in the last... That's just over a decade. In the last 12 years, or since C++11, Compiler Explorer is the best thing to happen. How do we know that?
这是我唯一赞助过的 Patreon 项目，那就是 Compiler Explorer。因为如果我花 10 美元买 YouTube Premium，花 30 美元买 Amazon Prime，没有什么东西是我用得比 Compiler Explorer 更多的。证据就是，在我做演讲的那个相同时间段里，每一个代码示例——不仅是 C++ 的，还有 C++ Circle 的——都有一个链接，并且都在这个网站上运行，也就是……你日常的代码开发有多少比例是用 Kotlin 写的？超过 50%。我再也不用终端了。我只用 Kotlin。
There's only one Patreon project I've ever sponsored, and that's Compiler Explorer. Because if I pay $10 for YouTube Premium and $30 for Amazon Prime, there's nothing that I use more than Compiler Explorer. Proof is that in the same time slot when I was giving my talk, every single code example, not just C++, but also C++ Circle, had a link and was running on this website, which is... What percentage of your day-to-day code development do you do in Kotlin? More than 50%. I don't use my terminal anymore. I just use Kotlin.
不，不，不。我今天早上看蒂娜（Tina）的演讲时，讲的是向 ranges 抛出工具。我试图打开我的 Linux 笔记本电脑，这电脑每隔一段时间就会崩溃一次。它崩溃了。当我重启它时，它会发出巨大的蜂鸣声。所以我不想在演讲中途搞那个。然后我意识到——因为肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）的 Circle 编译器可执行文件就在那台电脑上。
No, no, no. So literally, I was watching Tina's talk this morning, which was throwing tools at ranges. I tried to open my Linux laptop, which crashes every once in a while. It crashed. And when I restart it, it makes a big beeping noise. So I didn't want to do that in the middle of the talk. And then I realized, because that's where Sean Baxter's executable for the Circle compiler is.
没错。所以我当时想，哦，我猜我得等着把代码敲进去，看看能不能让她的代码在 Circle 上编译。然后我意识到，我在干什么？我直接打开我的另一台 Windows 笔记本电脑不就行了，它绝对不会崩溃，而且我可以直接在 Godbolt 上运行这个，因为所有的 Circle 相关东西都在上面。不管怎样，我们本来应该让马特在这里说话的。不，不，不，这样更好。这就像是我自己的节目一样。
Right. And so I was like, oh, I guess I got to wait to type this in to see if I can get her code to compile on Circle. And then I realized, what am I doing? Let me just open my other Windows laptop, which definitely doesn't crash, and I can just run this on Godbolt because all the Circle stuff is there. Anyways, we're supposed to be letting Matt talk here. No, no, no, this is better. This is like my own
对。所以当时我就想，哦，我得等会儿再输入这个，看看能不能在 Circle 上编译她的代码。然后我意识到，我这是在干什么？让我打开我的另一台 Windows 笔记本电脑，这台电脑绝对不会崩溃，我可以在 Godbolt 上运行它，因为所有的 Circle 相关的东西都在那儿。总之，我们本该让马特在这里说话的。不，不，不，这样更好。这就像我自己的
private podcast here. This is brilliant. Compiler Explorer is absolutely phenomenal. And let me say, Matt only paid us a very reasonable amount of money for this sponsored content. The point that we're getting to is that Matt is the creator of this website. And honestly, we're kind of joking, but it is actually like a transformative technology.
我们这里的私密播客。这太棒了。Compiler Explorer 绝对是现象级的。而且我得说，马特只付给我们非常合理的赞助费。我们要说的一点是，马特就是这个网站的创始人。老实说，我们虽然在开玩笑，但这确实是一项颠覆性的技术。
I think it really is. And not just C++, but other languages. Because it used to, if you wanted to just open up your laptop, if you wanted to just open up your laptop and start hacking away or prototyping something in C++, it used to be that you had to go open up a terminal and start hacking away or prototyping something in C++. It used to be that you had to go open up a terminal and go find your compiler and inevitably the compiler... It used to be worse than that.
我也觉得确实如此。不仅是 C++，其他语言也是。因为过去，如果你想打开笔记本电脑，如果你想打开笔记本电脑开始动手编写代码或用 C++ 进行原型设计，过去你必须打开终端，开始动手编写代码或用 C++ 进行原型设计。过去你必须打开终端，去找到你的编译器，而编译器难免会…… 过去情况比这还要糟糕。
When I was back in university in 2009, trying to install a C++ compiler was a weekend affair that would fail. Very early in my career, one of the first things I did was build the Linux kernel with Clang. I'm just like, why did I do that? Because I wanted to build the Linux kernel myself, but I also wanted to build the compiler I was using to build it myself. And I couldn't figure out how to build GCC.
2009 年我在上大学时，试图安装一个 C++ 编译器简直是一场会以失败告终的周末噩梦。在我职业生涯的早期，我做的第一件事之一就是用 Clang 构建 Linux 内核。我当时就在想，我为什么要这么做？因为我想自己构建 Linux 内核，但我也想自己构建我用来构建它的编译器。而且我弄不懂怎么构建 GCC。
So I was like, you know what? Building GCC was so complicated at the time. It'll just be easier to figure out how to get Clang to build Linux than to figure out how to build GCC. It sounds like an absolutely false statement, but I bet you learned a lot. At the time, I did learn a lot, and at the time, I think it was absolutely the right choice. So 10 minutes later, the point of this long monologue between Bryce and I is that Matt is the creator of this website, which is actually a big deal.
所以我就想，你知道吗？当时构建 GCC 太复杂了。搞清楚怎么用 Clang 构建 Linux，肯定比搞清楚怎么构建 GCC 要容易。这听起来完全是假话，但我敢打赌你学到了很多东西。当时我确实学到了很多，而且在当时，我认为这绝对是正确的选择。所以 10 分钟后，我和布莱斯进行这场冗长独白的核心意思是，马特是这个网站的创始人，这其实是一件大事。
So tell us a little bit about this website and how this dovetails into the talk slot is that I believe the name of your talk today is What is New in Compiler Explorer. So give us a small pitch. What is new in Compiler Explorer? I can't believe you even remembered where you were going with that. That's quite impressive. It's my one talent.
所以跟我们聊聊这个网站，以及这与你的演讲环节是如何契合的——我相信你今天的演讲主题是 Compiler Explorer 的新功能。所以给我们做一个简短的推介。Compiler Explorer 有什么新功能？我真不敢相信你还记得刚才话说到哪儿了。这太令人印象这是我唯一的才华。
Wow. You keep a hardware stack of where you were going. Right, right. I've noticed this by programmers we hate it when people forget where the conversation thread went because i think we do fear the stack overflow and the whatever anyway exactly so uh what's new in compiler explorer was a talk where i was luckily able to celebrate a whole bunch of things because like compiler explorer is not me anymore i i lend my my name
哇。你把刚才说到哪儿了用硬件栈记着呢。对，对。我注意到了，作为程序员，我们最讨厌别人忘记对话进行到哪个话题了，因为我觉得我们确实害怕栈溢出和诸如此类的事情，不管怎样，完全正确。所以，关于 Compiler Explorer 的新功能，这个演讲让我很幸运地能够庆祝一大堆事情，因为 Compiler Explorer 已经不再只属于我了，我只是把我的名字
to the domain name that's on and many people that include the person pointing the microphone at me right now call it my last name which is weird as hell to me but also i accept it's a shortened version of what it is and it's kind of cool so i'm down with it but um it celebrates the the sort of team of people who supply uh pull requests and who maintain the site and administrate it. And I am still in charge of all that nonsense, but there are so many cool things in the site that most people don't even know are there, right? There's views like the control flow graph.
借给了它所使用的域名，许多人——包括此刻正把麦克风对着我的人——直接叫它我的姓氏，这对我来说简直怪异极了，但我也接受，这是它名称的简写，而且还挺酷的，所以我欣然接受。但是，它旨在庆祝那些提交拉取请求、维护网站并对其进行管理的团队成员。我仍然负责所有这些乱七八糟的事情，但网站里有太多很酷的功能，大多数人甚至都不知道它们存在，对吧？比如控制流图这样的视图。
You can see the assembly and control flow mode. You can see the internals of the compiler. So many of the compilers have loads of crazy options to let you emit, like, optimization reports or, hey, at this point I did this, and then we can parse those files out. And so we've got a view where, for example, for Clang, this is my favorite one,
你可以看到汇编和控制流模式。你可以看到编译器的内部原理。许多编译器都有大量疯狂的选项，让你能够输出诸如优化报告之类的内容，或者，嘿，我在这一步做了这个，然后我们可以解析这些文件。所以我们有一个视图，例如对于 Clang 来说——这是我最喜欢的视图，
you can say, here's a bit of code, C++ code, compile it, show me the internal representation, and then show me every single pass. There's like 150 passes that your code goes through where various optimizations take place. And we show them in like a pane on the left-hand side. I believe we're about to be trolled. Uh-oh.
你可以说，这里有一段代码，C++ 代码，编译它，向我展示内部表示，然后向我展示每一个遍历（pass）。你的代码要经历大约 150 个遍历，期间会进行各种优化。我们将它们显示在左侧的一个面板中。我想我们马上就要被恶搞了。噢，不。
We are definitely about to be trolled. Yes, there is a troll here. Hello, troll. How's it going? Haven't you already had your slot with this? I didn't know it was a slot. It's a continuum. Yeah, it's a continuum.
我们绝对要被恶搞了。是的，这里有个恶搞的人。嗨，恶搞者。最近怎么样？你不是已经有过你的演讲环节了吗？我不知道这算是一个环节。这是一个连续体。对，这是一个连续体。
Yeah, it's not a slot. All right, all right, all right. All right, most important Capalix for a continuum. Yeah, it's a continuum. It's not a slot. All right. Most important Capilox question. Yes. Chat GPT integration win? I know. We've discussed it and I don't know how to do it for the best. But I hear somebody is giving a talk tomorrow that might get integration.
对，这不是一个环节。好啦，好啦，好啦。好了，最重要的问题。是的。ChatGPT 集成赢了吗？我知道。我们讨论过，但我不知道怎么做才是最好的。不过我听说明天有人要作一个可能包含集成的演讲。
I am. Possibly. Yeah. Have you finished your slides? I have finished my slides. I just have to make the slide notes. So I have content. I just don't know what I'm going to say about it. I mean, well, whoever knows what they're going to say about their slides. That's what they look for.
我。可能吧。是的。你写完幻灯片了吗？我写完幻灯片了。我只需要写幻灯片备注。所以我内容是有了。我只是不知道到时候要说些什么。我是说，谁会真的知道自己对着幻灯片会说些什么呢。大家不就看这个嘛。
Not Matt Gobble in his lightning talk today when he hit the summary slide. He was like, oh, and we're done. That was an old set of slides I hadn't looked at. I think we need some people to get that. We need to probably move back. No. So super excited to talk about what's new in Compiler Explorer. And there's a ton of it.
今天马特·戈布尔（Matt Godbolt）在他的闪电演讲（lightning talk）中可不是这样的，当他翻到总结幻灯片时。他当时就说，哦，讲完了。那是一套我很久没看过的旧幻灯片。我想我们得找人把那个截取下来。我们大概得退回去了。不。所以非常高兴能谈谈 Compiler Explorer 的新功能。内容多得不得了。
Go watch the slide that taught when it's up. Link in the show notes. There you go. It was quite good. Thank you. And you told us in advance you had 55 minutes of content, and you hit it right on the nose. That is impressive.
等幻灯片视频上线了去看吧。节目文稿中有链接。就是这样。非常不错。谢谢。而且你提前告诉我们你有 55 分钟的内容，结果你掐得丝毫不差。这太令人印象深刻了。
I have been practicing, my friend. That is a thing to do. See, I don't practice. I just hear it on me do my thing. It's like your podcast. Get us the look on Connor's face right now. I just, look, I just make this, honestly, I have not practiced a talk in five years.
我一直在练习，我的朋友。这就是该做的事。你看，我不练习。我只是听着它发生，然后做我该做的事。就像你们的播客一样。给我们看看康纳现在的表情。我只是，听着，老实说，我已经五年没有练习过演讲了。
I make the slide deck and I just have a gut feeling for how long it's going to be. Usually I'm within plus or minus two to three minutes. That's cool. I mean, it's good. Everyone has their own process. I can see that Connor and I, who actually, who talks the fastest out of us three? I think we're all... It's Connor. It's Connor.
我制作幻灯片，然后凭直觉去感觉它大概要讲多长时间。通常我的误差都在正负两到三分钟以内。这很酷。我是说，挺好的。每个人都有自己的流程。我能看出康纳和我——实际上，我们三个人里谁语速最快？我觉得我们都…… 是康纳。是康纳。
It's Connor. I feel but yeah, I think... So Connor tried to make me listen... When he's talking No, that's what he's talking about. Connor tried to make me listen to some's talking no Connor tried to make me listen to some podcasts on the road trip at like
是康纳。我觉得，但，是的，我觉得…… 所以康纳试图让我听…… 当他在说话时，不，这就是他在说的。康纳试图让我在公路旅行中听一些人的谈话，不，康纳试图让我在公路旅行中听播客，用大概
2 or 3x speed or whatever and it was like I don't I don't think Connor's human I really don't think he's human
2倍或3倍的速度，诸如此类的，当时我就觉得，我，我不认为康纳是人类，我真的不认为他是人类。
it's a it's a you just start increasing it and you don't notice Matt's got some thoughts yeah I'm exactly on that
这，这就像你不断调高速度，而你毫无察觉。马特有些想法。是的，我完全赞同这一点。
I'm regularly at 1.9 now. I can't quite make two comfortable. And sometimes when I'm walking the dog, I just need it to be back a bit slower because you kind of want to enjoy it. You forget sometimes that it's not just about the pure information being wired into your brain. It's actually kind of nice to listen to humans talking like normal humans. And I'm just looking around here and thinking, I don't see very many of them around here. Yeah, there really are not. There really are not.
我现在经常听 1.9 倍速。我还没法完全适应 2 倍速。有时我在遛狗时，我只想把它调慢一点，因为你其实想好好享受它。有时你会忘记，这不仅仅是把纯粹的信息输入你的大脑。听人类像正常人一样交谈其实是一件很美好的事。我环顾四周，心想，我在这里看不到几个这样的人。是的，真的没有。真的没有。
Alright, I think we should probably go talk with some other people. No, you got other questions? No, it's just JF wants to close. Yeah, JF. Any closing words of wisdom? Well, it's good to see you, Matt. Bryce, Connor, hi. You came over here to troll
好吧，我想我们大概应该去跟其他人聊聊了。不，你们还有别的问题吗？不，只是 JF 想做个总结。是的，JF。有什么临别赠言吗？很高兴见到你，马特。布莱斯，康纳，嗨。你们过来恶搞
But you had no agenda You're too Canadian, my friend Gentlemen, Bryce, good to see you Alright, we're going to wrap it there Let's go get our next set of people That was amazing Do you want to stay here and I'll get them Or should we both
但你们根本没有议题。你太加拿大风了，我的朋友。各位，布莱斯，很高兴见到你们。好了，我们就聊到这里吧。让我们去迎接下一组嘉宾。太棒了。你想呆在这儿我去把他们叫来，还是我们俩一起去？
Let's, we can walk Let's walk and talk Yeah, let's walk and talk Hey Jonathan, you want to stay here and I'll get them, or should we both? We can walk. Let's walk and talk. Yeah, let's walk and talk. Hey, Jonathan, you want to say hi? Hi. Do you just walk around and annoy people all evening? That's correct. Plug thinks so.
我们，我们可以走着去。我们边走边聊吧。对，边走边聊。嘿，乔纳森，你想呆在这儿我去把他们叫来，还是我们俩一起去？我们可以走着去。我们边走边聊吧。对，边走边聊。嘿，乔纳森，你想打个招呼吗？嗨。你整晚就到处闲逛去烦人吗？完全正确。普拉格也是这么想的。
How much do you guys pay? $130,000. Say link in the description. Link in the description. You know, here we are with Tristan Brindle, author of The Flux Library. He's giving a talk, Iteration Revisited Tomorrow. Should people go watch, even though they're listening to this after the talk has happened? They should absolutely come and watch my talk tomorrow.
你们付了多少钱？13,000 美元。说“请看节目说明中的链接”。节目说明中的链接。瞧，我们现在和特里斯坦·布林德尔（Tristan Brindle）在一起，他是《Flux 库》的作者。他明天将做一个题为《重访迭代》（Iteration Revisited）的演讲。人们应该去看吗，尽管他们听到这个时演讲已经结束了？他们绝对应该来看我明天的演讲。
Yes, 100%. And by people, we're talking to people of the world. And so link will be in the description when that talk goes online. You want to go over to the corner for this or what? What's the point? Great follow-up, Bryce. Tristan, good luck on your talk tomorrow. Tristan, did you figure out the homework problem that I gave you earlier?
是的，100%。这里说的“人们”，指的是全世界的人。所以当那个演讲上线时，链接会放在节目说明中。你们想为此去角落里聊，还是怎样？有什么意义呢？很好的追问，布莱斯。特里斯坦，祝你明天的演讲一切顺利。特里斯坦，你搞定我之前给你出的家庭作业题了吗？
The homework problem has not been top of my mind, but I will devote some brain power to it. All right, good. All right, thank you, Tristan. Good luck on your talk tomorrow. Thank you. All right, we're handing it over to Bryce. It might be a bit confusing on how this whole live interviews has gone down, but we are actually interviewing the co-hosts of three different podcasts.
家庭作业题没有占据我大脑的主要位置，但我会为此投入一些脑力的。很好。好的，谢谢你，特里斯坦。祝你明天演讲顺利。谢谢。好的，我们把话筒交给布莱斯。对于这次现场采访的整个过程，大家可能会觉得有点困惑，但我们实际上是在采访三个不同播客的主持人。
If that's not clear up until this point, that is definitely on Bryce. It is not on me. It's on Bryce. The first podcast we interviewed was with JF. That was, oh, Jesus. TLB Hit. The second podcast was Two's Compliment with Matt Gobble. Both of the co-hosts were not there, Chris and Ben, respectively. And now we are here with both co-hosts of the most popular C++ podcast of all time,
如果到现在还不清楚的话，这绝对是布莱斯的问题。不是我的问题。是布莱斯的问题。我们采访的第一档播客是 JF 的。那是，哦，天哪。TLB 命中（TLB Hit）。第二个播客是与马特·戈布尔合作的《Two's Compliment》。两位联合主持人都没在现场，分别是克里斯和本。现在我们和有史以来最受欢迎的 C++ 播客的两位联合主持人在一起，
the first C++ podcast of all time, handing it over to Bryce to do the introductions. And also the organizer of the conference that we are at, Mr. Phil Nash. Oh, Murray, how are you doing? We are doing pretty good. So what is the name of your podcast? Oh, I know this one. It's one of three, isn't it? I think it's currently CPPcast. That is a podcast with a long and storied history of excellence. So what do you think about this year's conference, Phil? I mean, why don't you tell us a little bit about the conference,
有史以来第一个 C++ 播客，将话筒交回给布莱斯来做介绍。还有我们所在的这次会议的组织者，菲尔·纳什（Phil Nash）先生。哦，穆雷，你好吗？我们挺好的。那么你们的播客叫什么名字？哦，我知道这个。是三个当中的一个，对吧？我想目前叫 CPPcast。这是一个历史悠久、充满卓越传统的播客。那么菲尔，你觉得今年的会议怎么样？我是说，你为什么不给我们简单介绍一下这次会议，
because you're the one that started this conference, yes? I am, yes. Well, this is the fifth year, but the third in person. But really, it's like the second in person, because last year was a reset. So it's all very complicated, really. But yeah, I've been running for five years, and I think it's going pretty well. Why did you decide to start a C++ conference south of London? Well, everyone else is doing it.
因为这个会议是你发起的，对吧？是的，是我。嗯，这是第五年，但也是第三次线下举办。不过实际上，有点像第二次线下举办，因为去年是一次重新开始。所以实际上挺复杂的。不过是的，我已经办了五年了，我觉得进展得挺顺利。你为什么决定在伦敦南部办一个 C++ 会议？嗯，其他人都在办。
I felt a bit left out. I don't know. There just seems to be a gap in the market at the time. I had some ideas what I wanted to do and thought I'd see how they pay out. What would you say makes this conference unique? Mostly the sea. Okay, fair enough. And what about you, Timur?
我感觉自己被冷落了。我不知道。当时似乎市场上存在一个空白。我有一些想做的事情的想法，并想看看它们效果如何。你觉得是什么让这次会议如此独特？主要是大海。好吧，有道理。蒂穆尔，你呢？
Why don't you tell people who you are, what you do? Hello, my name is Timur Dumler. I'm the co-host of CBPCast. I'm here at the CBP on Sea conference. Yeah. And where do you work i work at jet brains um we make tools for developers i'm a developer advocate there what what does it what is a developer advocate what does a developer advocate do well that's a good question it's kind of uh it has nothing to do with law, even though it has advocate in it. Although I guess that doesn't mean anything in English, does it?
你为什么不向大家介绍一下你是谁，你是做什么的？你好，我叫蒂穆尔·杜姆勒（Timur Dumler）。我是 CppCast 的联合主持人。我来到这里参加在海滨举行的 CBP（注：应为 Cpp）大会。是的。你在哪里工作？我在 JetBrains 工作，我们为开发者制造工具，我在那里担任开发者布道师（developer advocate）。开发者布道师是什么？开发者布道师是做什么的？这是一个好问题。它有点……
It's more other languages where advocate means something. This podcast is not legal advice. Consult your own lawyers, folks. Right, no, no. Anyway, so a developer advocate basically advocates for developers that use a developer-facing product. Like an IDE? Yeah, like we make IDEs and other developer-facing products, like we have a backtracker, we have a built server, that kind of stuff.
它和法律毫无关系，尽管里面带有“布道师/辩护人”（advocate）这个词。不过我想这在英语里什么也说明不了，对吧？在其他语言中，“advocate”可能更有实际意义。本播客不构成法律建议。请咨询您自己的律师，各位。没错，不，不。总之，开发者布道师基本上就是为使用开发者面向产品的开发者发声。就像 IDE 吗？对，就像我们制作 IDE 以及其他面向开发者的产品，比如我们有缺陷跟踪器，我们有构建服务器，诸如此类。
So on the one hand, I'm representing the developer community for the team, so I'm advocating for what the developer community actually wants, but also I kind of work with the team to make sure that we meet those needs. And I also create lots of content, like blog posts, videos. I go to talks, like conferences like this one. This is kind of very much part of my job as well. Kind of developer outreach, that kind of stuff. Yeah.
所以一方面，我在团队面前代表开发者社区，所以我为开发者社区真正想要的东西发声，但同时我也与团队合作，以确保我们满足这些需求。我还创作大量内容，比如博客文章、视频。我参加演讲，比如像这样的会议。这在很大程度上也是我工作的一部分。有点像开发者外联（developer outreach），诸如此类的事情。是的。
Teaching people how to write good code, how to use our products. Cool. So why should people listen to your podcast? Just talking to Timur about this, actually. So why should people listen to your podcast? Just talking to Timo about this, actually, he was saying that our podcast is almost like complete opposite, because we're sort of like very structured and follow a bit of a formula, whereas you're completely chaotic.
教人们如何编写优质代码，如何使用我们的产品。太酷了。那么人们为什么要听你们的播客呢？实际上我刚刚正在和蒂穆尔谈论这个。那么人们为什么要听你们的播客？其实我刚才正跟蒂穆尔聊起这个，他说我们的播客几乎就像是完全的对立面，因为我们非常结构化，遵循某种固定的模式，而你们则完全是混乱的。
But it's like we complement each other. I think we have room for both. Well, what is the structure? What does your podcast aim to deliver to its listeners? I think it's just a mixture of bringing some of the big names and the people who are really influencing the language and the direction that we're going
但这就好像我们互补一样。我觉得两者都有生存的空间。那么，结构是什么样的？你们的播客旨在为听众提供什么？我觉得这只是一种融合，既有邀请那些真正对语言以及我们在社区中前进的方向产生重大影响的大咖，
in in the community, as well as new voices, bringing them up to the fore and just letting people know what real world people are actually doing with C++. So the whole spectrum really. So we both kind of were very sad when Rob and Jason stopped doing it. And so we kind of both, I guess, independently thought, wouldn't it be great to revive it somehow?
也有带来新声音，把他们推到前台，让人们了解现实世界中的人们到底在用 C++ 做什么。所以确实是全方位的。所以当罗布（Rob）和杰森（Jason）停止制作时，我们俩都感到非常难过。所以我想我们俩基本上都独立地想过，以某种方式复活它不是很好吗？
But then we also didn't want to change too much stuff, right? Because it's been running for, what, like 10 years or something? Seven. Seven, yes. Of course, Connor would know that off the top of his head. Roughly 349 episodes. I should know that. It's mildly embarrassing.
但同时我们又不想改变太多东西，对吧？因为它已经运行了，什么，大概 10 年左右？7 年。7 年，是的。当然，康纳可以脱口而出这个数字。大约 349 期。我应该知道的。这有点小尴尬。
353 episodes. So you wanted to keep the formula as close as possible to what Rob and Jason were doing because we knew that it's going to be different, obviously, because we're different people, different personalities, but you wanted to keep the formula as close as possible so that's kind of what we're doing. I think it's kind of working. We're making little changes where it makes sense but we're going to keep the format
353 期。所以你们希望把模式尽可能保持得贴近罗布和杰森一直在做的事情，因为我们知道这肯定会不同，显然，因为我们是不同的人，有着不同的个性，但你们希望把模式尽可能保持得贴近原貌，所以这基本上就是我们一直在做的。我觉得这挺管用的。我们在合理的地方做了一些小改动，但我们会把这种形式
more or less as it is because we like it. I like it personally a lot. What's been your favorite thing at this conference this year? Tell me one thing that you've learned or found really interesting. As the conference organizer, I've only had time to actually see two talks. One of them was actually Timo's talk today on safety and C++.
大体上保持原样，因为我们喜欢它。我个人非常喜欢。今年会议上你最喜欢的是什么？告诉我一件你学到或者觉得非常有趣的事。作为会议组织者，我实际上只有时间看两场演讲。其中一场实际上就是蒂穆尔今天关于 C++ 安全性的演讲。
And I like the way he finished. I never thought I would say anything like this, but yes. What was... Can what was said be repeated on a podcast? We're about to find out. Right. So, apparently the last words of my talk were, use rust.
我喜欢他收尾的方式。我从没想过我会说出这样的话，但是是的。那是什么…… 演讲中说的话可以在播客里重复吗？我们马上就要知道了。好吧。所以，显然我演讲的最后一句话是，使用 Rust。
So, them fighting words. So, what was your talk about? It was about the whole safety and security debate that's been going on for a while, but quite intensely for the last year or so. And there were lots of talks, lots of reports, lots of news stories about how we have a big problem with safety in C++. And obviously we do, and we need to address it.
所以，这真是火药味十足的言论。那么，你的演讲是关于什么的？是关于一段时间以来一直在进行的安全与安全防护（safety and security）辩论，不过在过去一年左右的时间里相当激烈。有很多演讲、有很多报告、有很多新闻报道都在谈论我们在 C++ 的安全性方面存在大问题。显而易见我们确实有，我们需要解决它。
And we haven't maybe in our committee done a great job at that lately, but I wanted to provide a counterpoint, a little bit to this thing of oh, we're all doomed, C++ is going to die unless we figure out how to make it absolutely memory safe the way Rust is. And the point of my talk was, well, we can't really, unless we change it
而且我们在委员会里最近可能在这方面做得不是很好，但我想提供一个对立观点，稍微针对那种“我们都完蛋了，C++ 要消亡了，除非我们弄清楚如何像 Rust 那样让它绝对内存安全”的论调。我演讲的重点是，嗯，我们其实做不到，除非我们把它改变
so much that it's actually going to be a different language. But maybe we shouldn't. We should focus on what T++ is good at, improving safety where it makes sense and where we can, and just be very clear about that, but not be like, oh, we're all doomed unless it's all memory safe, because you can't really do that anyway. A lot of those points sound similar to points
得如此彻底，以至于它实际上成了另一门语言。但也许我们不应该这样做。我们应该专注于 C++ 擅长的领域，在合理且可行的地方提高安全性，并且对此保持非常明确的态度，而不是一副“哦，除非它是完全内存安全的，否则我们都完蛋了”的末日心态，因为你无论如何也做不到这一点。其中的很多观点听起来很相似
that were made in Sean Perrin's keynote the other day. It was actually funny because, so I submitted this talk because jf bastian nerd sniped me into submitting this talk on twitter i was like just tweeting hey what should i talk about and jf was like why don't you talk about safety and i was like okay because i don't understand how humor and irony works and so i just said okay i'm gonna do what he said so i submitted to talk about safety and then i found out from phil that you know sean is gonna do a keynote on the same topic so i was like oh well sean knows a lot of stuff that i don't so maybe i should just retract my talk but then actually got in touch with sean he was really
肖恩·佩伦（Sean Parent）前几天的基调演讲中提出的观点。其实挺搞笑的，因为我提交这个演讲是因为 JF 巴斯蒂安（JF Bastien）在 Twitter 上用“恶魔狙击（nerd sniped）”引诱我提交这个关于安全性的演讲，我当时只是发推文说，嘿，我该讲点什么呢？然后 JF 就说，你为什么不讲讲安全性呢？我就说，好吧，因为我不懂幽默和讽刺是怎么运作的，所以我当时就说，好吧，我要照他说的做。所以我提交了一个关于安全性的演讲，后来我从菲尔那里得知肖恩将要做一个关于同一主题的基调演讲，当时我就想，哦，好吧，肖恩知道很多我不知道的事情，所以也许我应该撤回我的演讲？但后来我实际上联系了肖恩，他人真的
lovely he spent like two hours with me on a call talked to me about you know his ideas what he wanted to talk about so i was like oh yeah there's ways in which I can make that complementary to that and, like, provide a different perspective and talk about different stuff that kind of complements that. So I hope I achieved that kind of a little bit, but, yeah, it was good fun. Okay, so you heard it here first from the host of CppCast, UsedRust.
很好，他在电话上花了大约两个小时和我交流，跟我聊他的想法、他想讲的内容，所以我就想，哦，是的，我可以通过某些方式让我的演讲与他的形成互补，提供不同的视角，谈论一些不同的东西来对他的演讲起到补充作用。所以我希望我达到了那种效果，不过，是的，过程挺好玩的。好吧，所以你们是从 CppCast 主持人这里听到的第一手消息：使用 Rust。
So I do have a question, Teamer, and I'm going to preface this by saying that my thesis is that you are C++'s biggest troll. I'm sorry, there's Victor. The biggest troll. He claimed you were C++'s biggest troll, which cannot possibly be true because of Mr. Victor. Yes, that's true.
那我有个问题，蒂穆尔，我在问之前先做个铺垫：我的论点是你是 C++ 界最大的恶魔/喷子。抱歉，还有维克托（Victor）。最大的恶魔。他声称你是 C++ 界最大的恶魔，这绝对不可能，因为有维克托先生在。是的，没错。
Okay, maybe C++'s second biggest. But here's my thesis, and this is why. You gave a 60-minute talk about C++ and safety. And the two major things that I took away from that talk were that C++ is not doomed, definitely not as doomed as people think it is, and two, that people are overblowing how important safety is. Not that it's not important, but that C++ prioritizes performance. However,
好吧，也许是 C++ 界第二大的。但我的论点是这样的，原因如下。你做了一个长达 60 分钟关于 C++ 与安全性的演讲。我从那个演讲中带走的两个主要观点是，C++ 并没有完蛋，绝对没有人们想象的那么完蛋；第二，人们把安全性的重要性夸大了。并不是说它不重要，而是 C++ 优先考虑性能。然而，
you then gave a lightning talk at the end of day two of this conference, aka a couple hours ago, where you proceeded to show one of the biggest gotchas that I've seen, and I can't reconcile how you say that C++ is okay and that safety is not important with your lightning talk, which everyone was just sort of,
随后你在大会第二天结束时做了一个闪电演讲——也就是几个小时前——在演讲中你展示了我在 C++ 中见过的最大的大坑（gotcha）之一，我无法将你所说的 C++ 很好、安全性并不重要，与你在闪电演讲中展示的内容调和起来，当时全场都差不多是那种反应，
and in your lightning talk, you had a gif of someone saying expletives silently three different times. I counted, Teamer. How do you reconcile those two things? What are you up to? Well, how do I answer that? What was the lightning talk? I mean, ask Timur.
在你的闪电演讲中，你放了一个动图，里面有人无声地说了好几次脏话。我数过，蒂穆尔。你怎么把这两件事调和起来？你到底在搞什么鬼？好吧，我怎么回答这个问题呢？那场闪电演讲讲的是什么？我是说，去问蒂穆尔。
Okay, so we have this feature called Lambdas, which is, you know, you have like a function that you define in an expression. You can pass that to other functions. And apparently it's so hilariously complicated that I actually spent quite a lot of time preparing a one-hour talk about how this works last year. And then actually at your conference, Connor, the one that you were about how this works last year. And then actually at your conference, Connor, the one that you were the program chair of last year.
好吧，我们有一个叫 Lambda 的特性，就是，你知道的，你有一个在表达式中定义的函数。你可以把它传给其他函数。显然它复杂得令人捧腹，以至于我去年实际上花了很多时间准备了一个一小时的演讲来讲解它是如何运作的。然后实际上在你的大会上，康纳，就是去年由你担任程序委员会主席的那个大会。
And then after doing all of this work, I still have no clue how Lambdas actually work because literally the next day somebody came to me and said, hey, I have a Lambda here. I don't understand why it does the thing that it does. And I was like, what? And then I looked into the standard to try to understand what's going on.
在做了所有这些工作之后，我依然对 Lambda 到底是如何运作的毫无头绪，因为 literalmente（字面意思）就在第二天，有人来找我，说，嘿，我这里有个 Lambda。我不明白为什么它会做出它所做的那种行为。当时我就想，什么？然后我查阅了标准试图弄清楚到底发生了什么。
I was like, what? And then I looked into the standard, tried to understand what was going on. I was like, what? And, like, so it's this weird thing where, kind of, I've been doing C++ for a long time, and here's the thing. I'm learning more C++, right? As I go, as I do these talks, I work, I write C++ during the day, so I learn more C++.
我就想，什么？然后我查阅了标准，试图弄清楚到底发生了什么。我就想，什么？所以，这是一个奇怪的事情，某种程度上，我使用 C++ 已经很长时间了，情况是这样的。我正在学习更多的 C++，对吧？随着我的前行，当我做这些演讲时，我白天也写 C++，所以我学到了更多的 C++。
But the language actually gets more complicated and bigger faster than I can learn it, which means that the relative proportion of C++ that I know actually shrinks over time. And I find that quite fascinating. It's quite a unique property for a programming language, I think. So I haven't really figured out
但语言本身变得复杂和庞大的速度，比我学习它的速度还要快，这意味着我所掌握的 C++ 相对比例实际上随时间在缩小。我觉得这相当迷人。我认为这对于一门编程语言来说是一个相当独特的属性。所以我其实还没有搞清楚
how to reconcile that with anything, really. But yeah, I guess that's... I don't know what my point is, but this is kind of... Use Rust. Yeah. In closing, what did Phil just say? In closing...
如何把这一点与任何事情调和起来。不过，是的，我想这就是…… 我不知道我的重点是什么，但这就是…… 使用 Rust。是的。最后，菲尔刚刚说什么了？最后……
Use Rust. All right. I think we're going to wrap there. In closing, what did Phil just say? Use Rust. All right. I think we're going to wrap there. I think we're good. Thank you, guys. This was a lot of fun. Thank you, guys.
使用 Rust。好吧。我想我们要在那儿结束了。最后，菲尔刚刚说什么了？使用 Rust。好吧。我想我们要在那儿结束了。我觉得我们讲好了。谢谢你们，伙计们。这太有趣了。谢谢你们，伙计们。
Thank you so much. Thank you. And also, as we're closing, any exciting things or different things that are happening in 2024 for C++ on C? Or they should just tune in to the Twitters? On a different C. If people want to follow the latest and greatest, the upcoming news, what should they do? That's a good question. There will definitely be a C++ on C
非常感谢。谢谢。另外，在我们结束之际，2024 年 C++ on Sea 会有什么激动人心或与众不同的事情发生吗？还是大家只需关注 Twitter？在另一个 C。如果人们想关注最新、最棒的消息和即将到来的新闻，他们应该怎么做？这是一个好问题。2024 年肯定会有 C++ on Sea
2024. It's going to be slightly bigger, I'm hoping. And judging by how this week went, I think there are going to be at least three coffee machines. So you heard it here first. Come to C++ and see for the best coffee.
会议。我希望它会稍微大一点。从这周的进展来看，我认为至少会有三台咖啡机。所以你们是头一个听到这个消息的。来 C++ on Sea 喝最好的咖啡吧。
We're going to wrap here. We still got one more person we got to interview. That's true. And who is that person? Mr. Sean Parent. It's been too long, Sean. We're having you. Except we're coming for you. This will probably be the end of episode 136, I believe. And so you'll hear from Sean
我们要在这里收尾了。我们还有一个必须采访的人。没错。那个人是谁？肖恩·佩伦先生。太久没见了，肖恩。我们要找你。不过我们要来找你了。这大概会成为第 136 期的结尾，我想。所以你们会听到肖恩的声音
next week because this podcast is already over 40 minutes. And don't worry, we have heard your requests for more Sean and there is a lot more Sean coming in the future. There's a lot more Sean coming in the future, folks. Alright. Be sure to check the
就在下周，因为这个播客已经超过 40 分钟了。别担心，我们听到了你们关于想要更多肖恩内容的请求，未来还会有更多关于肖恩的内容。未来还会有更多关于肖恩的内容，各位。好的。请务必查看
show notes for links to everything that we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to the GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目说明，里面有今天节目中提到的一切内容的链接，还有一个 GitHub 讨论区的链接，你可以在那里留下评论、想法和问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家过愉快的一天。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。